so wait you must have met a lot of
presidents like over your time so did
you meet Reagan did I hear that yeah
when I was just not in my career I got
to the White House correspondent that
was the scariest one the first time I
did the White House Correspondence
Dinner like I'm backstage and it's all
political people and some show people
but
and I'm standing backstage in the wings
and Miss General comes in like this he's
got all the he goes hey you're the
community come here come here I go
okay that's the president United States
you understand that that is my
commander-in-chief he's doing this
that's my communities I go yes he's
doing that to you yeah he goes you don't
denigrate him you don't make fun of him
he is the president United States he is
my commander do you understand I'm gonna
tell you I said yes yes sir yeah okay
he's a big Huffer fine he leaves I go oh
man I gotta change my ACT here you know
you know
and then about about two minutes later
remember George Schultz Secretary of
Defense he George Schultz coming he's
got a drink he goes and he's like three
sheets to the wind at this point he goes
Leno come here come here
you get out there you nail Ronnie's ass
to the wall
and I go totally different I don't want
that General and screw him he works for
me
I'm telling you what to do you make fun
of that black thing on Reagan's head you
understand
I don't know what to do now now I'm like
what did you do oh I nailed him to the
wall
you had an out they told you to yeah I I
remember the opening joke was uh was uh
I want to watch it Nancy Reagan I'm
being named uh humanitarian of the year
I'm glad she beat out that conniving
little Mother Teresa that was a
joke
when Reagan laughed at that then I knew
I was in it's like when they're all
watching is he think it's funny yeah
yeah when you do the white that's what
they do they look at the president oh
and then they left that's exactly what
happened
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]